what are the biggest obstacles to  increasing the variety in a manner fear  the others well you know take for  example we've had a charter school law  since 1998 we have for charters it's not  because there's no demand I know people  have a demand for it but people really  understand what charter schools are they  still think they're private schools they  think they cream the best and brightest  kids and they believe they'll lead to a  racial segregation three things that  just across the board charter schools  have not shown to be the case I think  its fear the unknown and second this is  generational change you know you have  people under 40 opening up multi-million  dollar schools that superintendents and  principals when they were 40 never would  have had the opportunity to do so i  think it's generational as well but you  know there's common cause across the  board and make sure that you know age  and zip codes will be a factor of it at  ideals matter